ADDY OSMANI: Hey guys, we are
live on the Chrome Developer
channel for the Chrome
Office Hours.
I think it will be useful for us
to go around the room just
to see who everybody is.
Paul?
PAUL KINLAN: Hi, I'm Paul,
as Addy just said.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google.
I've worked Chrome,
Web Intents.
And I'm looking forward
to loads of Web
Intents questions today.
I don't see any on the list.
I'm want you to come and ask
some, otherwise I probably
won't be speaking today.
Sorry, guys.
PAUL LEWIS: Hey,I'm
Paul Lewis.
I'm a developer programs
engineer for Google,
obviously, working on Chrome,
Chrome apps, GPU, and
performance kinds of things.
ADDY OSMANI: I'm Addy.
I work on Yeoman tooling, some
developer docs, and one two
other bits.
PAUL IRISH: I'm Paul Irish.
Paul.
I'm working on all sorts of
HTML5, openware platform, dev
tools, Yeoman, good stuff.
SAM DUTTON: My name
is Sam Dutton.
I'm here in London working on
Chrome devrel, I'll be working
on WebRTC, and doing more
mobile Chrome stuff.
PAUL IRISH: So we have a Google
moderator setup that
you can go and submit questions
to and vote up and
down on other people's questions
so that we answer
exactly the stuff that you
are interested in.
So if you can, just
open up the
developers.google.com/live,
and you'll see
that we're on air.
Click through that, and then
you'll see the moderator right
there, where you can submit
questions and put things up.
So this is just Office Hours,
and we're just going to answer
your questions.
So we're guided by
you guys today.
SAM DUTTON: We're planning to
do this on a pretty regular
basis from London now, so we're
really looking forward
to more of your questions.
ADDY OSMANI: So let's dive in.
PAUL LEWIS: Cool.
The first question that we're
going to get into comes from
the United Kingdom
from Simon Owen.
He asked, are we going to see
a FireSass equivalent or
similar in Chrome?
And so he's talking about the
FireSass extension for FireBug
adding in support of the Sass
stylesheet [INAUDIBLE].
So we've been looking at this
and really want to have some
good, powerful stuff.
There's a patch that's
brewing.
It has not landed yet, as a
straw-man attempt, where you
can actually see Sass files
inside the Sources panel in
the Chrome dev tools.
And so that's the first step.
We'll see where it
goes from there.
But we're investigating and
writing Chrome right now.
PAUL KINLAN: So are you going
to use source maps?
PAUL LEWIS: As far as I know,
it's not actually using source
maps just yet.
Although the cool thing
is that the original
implementation of source maps
was refactored to allow for
more flexibility when it came
to CSS source maps.
So while what's implemented
right now is not taking
advantage of that, there's
plumbing to enable that.
So that patch will actually
land today or tomorrow.
So if you're on Canary,
you'll be able to see
the begins of that.
The other thing I wanted to
mention is if you Google for
Web Inspector Commits RSS,
you're going to get an RSS
feed of all the commits to
WebKit that are just the
WebKit Inspector, which
is from dev tools.
And you can see everything
that lands, including new
features and small bug fixes and
stay very close to what's
coming down the pipe.
Next question?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Moving on to a question here
from [INAUDIBLE], are you
planning to make Chrome desktop
sharing extensions
support voice chat, work around
firewalls so we can
interact with our site users
like with Skype, but totally
over the web?
Well, none of us here work
on that extension.
We have passed the question
on to the team.
I'd like to take this
opportunity to give a plug for
WebRTC, which does a lot of
what you're talking about.
I've said already.
It allows video chat and enables
NAT traversal, so
getting through firewalls
and so on.
So take a look at that.
We've got a great WebRTC
article now on
HTML5 rocks dot com.
We'll have a little
on webrtc.org.
Great way to chat with people,
and it's all in the browser,
plug-in free.
PAUL KINLAN: So that would be
for his screensharing as well.
So you are talking about doing
WebRTC at the same time as
screenshare?
SAM DUTTON: I'm not sure if
the question here is about
doing video chat or specifically
about doing
desktop sharing.
We'll ask the promoting
team about working--
PAUL KINLAN: Because I've seen
some stuff that use the
Mutation Observers as well to
get the screen on someone
else's remote screen.
PAUL IRISH: Next question
comes from [? Keviex ?]
in the United States.
He says, a question regarding
V8 flags in Chrome.
So there's a lot of flags that
you can pass into the V8
Javascript engine that allow
you to implement tracing.
And this is actually
pretty cool.
In a very high performance
environment, you want to know
when it goes into Crankshaft,
which is
the optimize compiler.
And you can see what goes into
that heavily optimized route
and then back out and, perhaps,
get an indication of
your code that is keeping it
from going into a highly
optimized route.
There's a great talk, I think,
at Google I/O about V8 and
optimization, where you can
learn more about this.
But [? Keviex ?] is asking, can
anyone give instructions
on using these flags inside
Chrome to get this?
So for this one, Chrome has
flags that you can run against
the executable.
So if you just Google
for running
Chrome flags, I think--
a while ago I made a page that
has the instructions.
Basically, you need to run
Chrome from the command line,
and then you can
pass in flags.
Every available flag is
listed on peter.sh.
So if you just look for
that, you can find it.
But there's a specific technique
of passing in V8
flags through a Chrome flag.
So it's like you wrap the
V8 flags in a warm
hug of other flags.
SAM DUTTON: So you can
do it from Chrome
flags, in other words?
PAUL IRISH: You can do it.
So the name of the Chrome
flag is V8 Flags.
And you pass it a string
of other flags.
Yeah, that's nice.
But that way you are able to
get this output dumped into
your terminal, as far
as V8's behavior.
PAUL KINLAN: So are there
any tools that
consume that output?
Or is it, literally, your
just go in and?
PAUL IRISH: I haven't
seen any.
That would be really cool.
I haven't seen it.
Next question.
SAM DUTTON: Wow, we got some
more questions coming in.
PAUL IRISH: Good, keep
them coming.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
fire them in.
PAUL IRISH: Please, vote
up and down on
anybody else's questions.
PAUL KINLAN: I've seen someone
mention Web Intents.
SAM DUTTON: We got get
him more questions.
PAUL KINLAN: We'll do that
one later, alright?
I'll save them for last.
SAM DUTTON: The last question
is a good one.
PAUL IRISH: Are there any known
IDE or tools to take
advantage of remote debugging
support API to enhance web
developer resources?
So this cool.
One of the extension APIs inside
Chrome is actually
called the Debugger API.
And this is actually a JSON feed
of the remote debugging
protocol that is used for remote
debugging and also,
actually, for the Web Inspector
application in the
web app, just to communicate
with the host page.
So it actually just communicates
over the same
protocol that it uses for
remote debugging.
And that protocol is exposed
via an extension.
What this allows is you could
create, in a page, your own
complete API--
I'm sorry, UI, for all
of Chrome dev tools.
One particularly great
application is, let's say, you
have a web based IDE.
You could be showing code, and
then you have your set
breakpoint, pause, step into,
step out of, and all that
would be proxied through
the dev tools plumbing.
And you get to control the
API inside the UI.
So it's really exciting.
And as far as people who are
taking advantage of this right
now, there is a plug-in for
Eclipse that allows you to
debug your JavaScripts over in
Eclipse and it just routes
through them and uses the
debugger protocol.
And that's, I think,
it these days.
Adobe has a new web based
IDE called Brackets.
And I've talked to them
about this API.
And so they've looked at it.
Nothing has landed
as far as I know.
But it could be pretty
rad if we saw an
implementation there.
PAUL KINLAN: So is the
protocol over TCP?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Interesting.
I was just thinking because,
obviously, Chrome Apps, the
packaged apps, have got access
to UDP and TCP connections.
So you can make a little Chrome
App like, right now, on
the Dev and Canary channel,
which would talk to the
instance of Chrome and have a
debugger inside your own web
app type of thing.
PAUL IRISH: I think it's
actually a WebSocket
connection.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, is that
a WebSocket one?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
There's actually a great article
if you're interested
in extending the dev tools.
There's a really good article
by our colleague Boris Smus.
If you Google for
extending Chrome
Developer Tools Boris Smus--
that's S-M-U-S--
that's a really great place
to learn about building
extensions for the
Chrome tools.
But also, if you want to
actually add stuff to your own
custom frontend.
So good information there
about doing extra
things for the tools.
PAUL KINLAN: Is that
like extra panels
and stuff as well?
SAM DUTTON: Yes.
It's actually information about
building a new frontend
or tweaking, adding on to
the existing frontend.
There's good information there
about building extensions
using the dev tools
extensions, APIs.
PAUL KINLAN: Because we'll have
to do a Web Intents--
I'm going to mention Web Intents
every single time.
It's the Web Intent that I
write that [INAUDIBLE].
Because we're thinking about
doing like a dev tools custom
panel to tell you what
information was being passed
into an app [INAUDIBLE].
ADDY OSMANI: So the next
question is, how will the
divergence of the W3C and
WHATWG on the HTML5 spec
affect Chrome?
And I guess the answer to that
is, it won't really.
We're actively involved
in both.
And we're hoping that the
differences there are going to
stay minor.
PAUL IRISH: The other thing to
point out is that the Chrome
team is involved in working
groups on the
W3C, also the WHATWG.
This is not the first time
that there's been a
divergence.
For instance, inside the WHATWG
HTML spec, it includes
the Canvas 2D API.
But that is in its very own
spec over in W3C land.
And there's wording differences
and things like
that already.
So there has been
a divergence.
Well, I don't know if it's
more of a divergence, but
there is new editors as well.
We expect not much of an effect
at all on how Chrome
operates and is developed.
ADDY OSMANI: So the next
question is, as the Web SQL
feature was deprecated from
HTML5 spec, are you planning
to remove it from Chrome
in the future?
Web SQL is interesting.
Dropping it from the web
platform is difficult, because
there are people actively
using it at the moment.
And if we want to do that, one
prerequisite is that things
like IndexDB, for example, get
broader support and start
getting used a little
bit more.
We do see Web SQL, perhaps,
getting dropped at sometime in
the foreseeable future, but,
again, people need to start
using IndexDB, for example,
a little bit more.
PAUL KINLAN: So the question I
was going to ask is, do we
know of any abstraction layers
which just get rid of the
differences between the two, I
mean, that we can kind of tell
people right now?
PAUL IRISH: Between Web
SQL and IndexDB?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
so don't have to
particularly worry too much.
I mean, if you're going to
develop an app now, and you
want just to store later?
SAM DUTTON: Right, you
mean like Lawnchair
and stuff like that.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I mean, Lawnchair, Data Backbone
has got these couple
different plug-ins--
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, there are
a bunch of different sync
plug-ins for Backbone that you
can get that allow you to
switch the storage options that
you use, whether it be
IndexDB or something else.
But as Sam mentioned, there's
also Lawnchair, which a lot of
people are using
at the moment.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, in a way it's
tricky, because Lawnchair
has asynchronous API, as
far as I remember.
You want to have a asynchronous
API, because the
browser likes when you're
acting in an
asynchronous fashion.
And so if you want something
that's like simple and has
great browser support, just
use local storage.
And if you're going to go a
little bit more complicated
than that, and you need better
performance, and you need
better data consistency, you
might end up writing the
adapters yourself.
But I don't like recommending
that.
PAUL LEWIS: Got to be
driving the market.
ADDY OSMANI: You can post a
response to questions inside
the moderator.
If you have a suggestion for a
storage library that handles
Web SQL and IndexDB and,
hopefully, is also
asynchronous, drop it in there,
because it's hard to
capture all the possible
libraries there.
Simon Sarris, who is a Canvas
expert in New Hampshire, he
asked about scrollbars.
So in Chrome, when you do a
Control F find you get little
highlights on the scrollbar to
indicate page position, where
all the matches are.
And sometimes, when you
customize the scrollbar with
CSS, that effect is lost.
So he's asking, do we get to
retain that functionality,
somehow, while still having
customer styling on
scrollbars?
Great question.
PAUL KINLAN: Do we
know an answer?
Because I was just think--
do we?
No?
No answer.
Because I was thinking
about this.
I remember doing something like
this a while ago where,
in custom CSS, you could,
basically, just manipulate it
with the Canvas, essentially,
like the background.
It wasn't necessarily a
background image, but you
could, essentially, attach
the Canvas to it.
And I can't remember, for the
life of me, how I did it.
But because the scrollbars in
WebKit are startable, and you
can get access to the thumb, the
background, and the little
bits at the top and bottom, I
was wondering whether you do
the same type of thing
there as well.
The height and width, you can
get the Canvas and say, well,
the background image for this
scrollbar is the output from
this Canvas.
I've not seen it done.
Well, I've seen it done in other
apps, but I've never
seen the solution, if
that makes sense
PAUL IRISH: I feel like it's a
totally legit feature request
to ask for custom styling
for the match
markers in the scrollbar.
If we have a styling
[INAUDIBLE]
like -WebKit -scrollbar -match,
or whatever, and then
you might take it from that
yellow and change it into
something that matches what
you've styled it into.
If we had that then there would
be no reason to hide it
automatically when it styles.
And so file a ticket and see
what folks think, because I
think that would be awesome.
PAUL LEWIS: So the next question
from Stewart is, will
Chrome for Android follow a
similar frequent release
schedule to the desktop
version?
And are there any plans for
dev and Canary versions?
The simple answer is, yes, we
intend to follow the Chrome
release cycle, but we don't
have an ETA for this,
specifically, at the moment.
When we do, we'll announce
it publicly.
But what we can say is that we
will be following the dev beta
stable Canary release pattern
that you've seen on desktop.
ADDY OSMANI: So the next
question is, are you planning,
soon, to implement the device
orientation locking by the
view port orientation preview
in the Chrome mobile and
Android default browser?
So we're investigating what APIs
are important to have on
mobile at the moment.
That includes the orientation
lock.
We're aware of it We're looking
at it at the moment.
But we don't have anything
to announce just yet.
I know it's not the best
answer, but it's what
you get right now.
Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: Stewart asks
do you know of any work
implementing the Web Audio API
for Chrome for Android?
Web Audio API is used in--
was it used in Exquisite
Forest?
Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: It was used
in the WebChrome
mobile app as well.
PAUL IRISH: The new Chrome
[INAUDIBLE] was for Forest,
which I recently released,
experiments and arty stuff.
It's really cool.
And it's not currently
available
in Chrome for Android.
What you can do is, if you go to
mcrbug.com, it's a list of
all the tickets that are filed
against Chrome for Android.
And one of them in there,
towards the top, you'll see,
is Web Audio support.
Star this ticket to
stay notified.
Right now, there's
not any support.
One of the things that would be
really useful to hear is,
if you're a mobile developer,
and you could really use Web
Audio support, and you just said
the audio tag doesn't cut
it for you, leave a not saying
what your use case is.
What is that you want to build,
so people have a better
idea as far as what is the
possibility of this feature?
I've heard a lot of people say
that Web Audio API makes a lot
sense in desktop settings, but
on a phone or a tablet, it's
not as obvious.
So having a broader
understanding of what people
are going to make would help a
lot as far as helping people
understand the priority
of this should be.
SAM DUTTON: If you're in London,
go to the Science
Museum and check out--
PAUL KINLAN: You know, I should
have said that, man.
SAM DUTTON: Paul's your man--
PAUL KINLAN: Check out the
Science Museum, Chrome Weblab.
It's awesome.
SAM DUTTON: It's really nice.
PAUL IRISH: What is it?
PAUL KINLAN: It's five, real
world, interactive
experiments, Chrome experiments
that you can
interact with from anywhere
in the world on the web or
interact with directly from
the Science Museum.
There's an interactive
orchestra, sand drawing box,
which you take a picture
of your face,
draw it in the sand.
You have to go check it out.
It's really cool.
It's beautiful as all.
PAUL LEWIS: In the meantime,
if you can't,
chromeweblab.com, would
be the place to visit.
PAUL IRISH: We went there
just last night.
And it was totally cool.
Got an understanding of how
everything was built, all
built with Chrome and web
technologies, even some
Node.js and Arduino in there.
PAUL KINLAN: So we'll do some
Hangouts, as well, soon, with
some of the people who have
built the project.
I've haven't got an exact ETA
when it's going to happen.
ADDY OSMANI: Are they going to
talk us through how these
things were used?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, we want to
do one talk per experiment,
from top to bottom, from client
to server, show you how
it was built.
PAUL IRISH: So neat.
PAUL KINLAN: It's
going to be fun.
PAUL IRISH: Next question, Simon
asks about some of the
new Canvas functionality that's
been added to the spec.
I think this happened circa
March, April, is when it
actually hit the spec.
There's new functionality
and features for
Canvas that are in there.
But I don't think we've seen
it in any browser yet.
As far as ETA, I can't say.
I just don't know.
But the best way to check this
out on the WebKit tracker.
So what I just did is I
just looked up one of
these, found a ticket.
Right now it's assigned to Gene
Jackson, who is commonly
a spec editor for
a lot of specs.
And he has a lot of them
assigned to him.
So it looks like there's
certainly interest from
implementers.
But I haven't seen any
patches prepared yet,
so watch the tickets.
And that's as much as
we know right now.
If you're just joining
us, hello.
We are going through a
bunch of questions.
You go to
developers.google.com/live,
click on are Chrome Office
Hours, and there's a bunch of
questions you can vote
up, down, and ask.
PAUL KINLAN: There are
quite a few now.
It's good.
PAUL IRISH: Vote up
and down more.
Upsell.
SAM DUTTON: Who is going
to take this next one?
Bunch of questions.
PAUL IRISH: This is good.
Mosen from LA, he has asked some
stuff about Web Forms.
First, input type color added to
HTML5 spec a long time ago.
It's been implemented in
Chrome and WebKit?
I know about Chrome.
I'm not sure about Safari
and other ports.
But it, right now, brings up
the operating systems color
picker widget.
Mosen is asking, why does
it do this versus
your own color picker?
PAUL KINLAN: When he says, your
own color picker, does he
mean one that you'd write
yourself or like a
standardized Chrome one?
ADDY OSMANI: I guess he means a
general one, something that
might write tehmselves.
PAUL IRISH: I don't know.
I don't have a great answer.
My guess is that it's probably
better for all browsers to use
the native operating systems
picker than all browsers have
inconsistent color pickers with
different functionality.
When you leave it up the OS you
present something that is
probably more familiar
to the user than what
one implementer thought.
And so I think that consistency
is pleasant.
Plus it probably is nicer to get
that feature out quicker,
because you can leverage
something instead of rolling
it all from scratch.
Mosen also asked about input
type week and type time.
Those are not supported well.
Type date is.
And why that is, I think they're
just a matter of
priorities.
Everyone needs a
date in there.
ADDY OSMANI: It's a
matter of time.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it's
a matter of time.
PAUL IRISH: I like it.
PAUL LEWIS: Sounds good.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it
was good, wasn't it?
PAUL IRISH: Everyone needs date
pickers, and so laying
that first certainly
made sense.
There are tickets.
I think I have a link, on the
Web Kit Bug Tracker, ticket
number 86990.
Actually, if I can show you.
Can we bring up my screen?
Great.
Cool.
It's coming up in
just a moment.
So right now, this ticket--
And of my favorite features is
to view the dependency tree.
So for any ticket you can
understand what are the things
that have to happen before this
ticket can get closed and
patch plan this?
What is this blocking?
And dependency trees, on the
Web Kit Tracker are pretty
nice to understand how the
whole thing will be
implemented and the progress
of something.
So, in this case, we can do
that, see what's already been
resolved in this tree.
And you can see that quite a few
things, a good 90% of what
is needed for this feature
is complete.
So take a look at that.
ADDY OSMANI: The next question
is about Yeoman.
Louie Lopez from Spain writes,
what kind of support shall we
expect for AngularJS?
Good question.
So with V1 of Yeoman, we are
going to be including a really
nice scaffold for AngularJS,
which will hopefully let you
do a little bit of what an
existing project called
Angular-Seed lets you do.
Which is sort of scaffold out
a brand new Angular project
and maybe one or two
other things.
We're actually actively working
with the Angular team
to try getting a little boiler
plate that has best practices
into there.
And so our support for it out
of the box is going to be
pretty decent.
For anybody that sort of is
more concerned with other
frameworks, like perhaps
Backbone or Ember, we're going
to, hopefully, in the future,
work with the people involved
in those projects to create
similar scaffolds.
But we've been working with
proof of concepts that already
work with Backbone and Ember.
So far, they work great.
And I think it's just going to
be the case of, once Yeoman is
out, you'll start to see more
of these generators and
scaffolds come out soon
after, hopefully.
PAUL LEWIS: And if somebody is
not familiar with what Yeoman
is, as a tool, could you give
us like the elevator pitch?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, of course.
So Yeoman is an opinionated
workflow for developers that
will, hopefully, help them
build more beautiful
applications.
We try to take a look
at aspects of
their development process.
Everybody needs a build process
of some sort, using a
build tool.
People like the idea of not
having to manually write out a
lot of the boiler-plate coding
needed for projects.
So Yeoman is also to going
to take care of that.
We've got a bunch of other
neat stuff in there.
We've got support for headless
WebKit testing.
We've got a watch process.
You're able to write, for
example, Coffee Script or
Compass and have that
automatically compile using
[? iReload ?]
and a bunch of other things.
So you won't even have to go
back and manually compile
things yourself.
But we've got some other
features in there too.
PAUL KINLAN: Does it support
Web Intents?
SAM DUTTON: Yes.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
ADDY OSMANI: That was
the first feature,
before anything else.
SAM DUTTON: Shameless.
PAUL KINLAN: It doesn't
matter.
You're not going to actually
launch with it.
ADDY OSMANI: Oh, god no.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I'll work on it.
I'll get it in.
It'll be good.
ADDY OSMANI: That's
your evenings
cleared up right there.
PAUL IRISH: The next question
comes from JahRomero.
And it's asking, are there any
plans to allow side-by-side
installs of different Chrome
channels on Linux?
So Chrome Canary is available
on Windows and Mac.
And Chrome Canary, I think, is
fantastic for developers.
I know, I run Chrome Stable
and then Chrome Linux
side-by-side all the time.
You guys, is that
how you roll?
PAUL KINLAN: Well, I tend to get
the latest Chromium build
every night from Linux.
PAUL IRISH: So Chrome Canary
works great for Mac and
Windows, but there's a lot
of people on Linux.
And I understand that not having
Canary is a bummer.
There are builds, depending
on what flavor you're on.
I know there is a package that's
maintained for Ubuntu,
for a nightly Chromium build.
And so take a look around
for maintained
unstable Chromium packages.
That updates every night.
Otherwise, there's plenty of
scripts that people have
written, just batch scripts that
go and fetch it on the
fly for you.
Is yours just like you have
it set on chron job?
PAUL KINLAN: I've just got a
bookmark to the directory
where they are, and I download
it when it's up.
But I've seen some scripts,
like shell scripts, which
just, basically, pull it in.
And it will work quite nice.
PAUL IRISH: If you do want an
absolute edge Chromium build,
you can go to
downloadchromium.appspot.com,
which just sniffs out what OS
you're on and gives you one
single click.
Because finding that actual
directory is kind of a pain.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
And it changed a while
ago, right?
PAUL IRISH: Yep.
ADDY OSMANI: So Hussein from
Colorado writes, what parts of
the Chrome ecosystem is the
team most excited about--
PAUL KINLAN: Web Intents.
ADDY OSMANI: No.
I haven't finished
the sentence, and
he's already on it.
It doesn't have to be one thing,
Yeoman, AngularJS,
HTML5 features.
I think it will useful
to go around.
I can't imagine what you'd
most interested in.
PAUL KINLAN: So I'm actually
interested in helping
developers just build great
web apps quickly and have
great web apps to talk
to each other.
I mean, that's the problem I've
always face on the web is
that you don't have to do really
deep integrations and
just building all these
things is really hard.
So anything that makes my life
easier, to build great web
apps, is good.
So things like Yeoman,
I'm excited about.
I've used Backbone quite
a bit recently.
I've not really tried Angular,
but I've heard a lot of good
things, those type of things.
Anything that makes
it easy for me.
PAUL LEWIS: Me, I'm
kind of excited--
I guess I'm similar on this, but
WebRTC, for me, is one of
the things.
Because it's quite disruptive
thing to see coming through.
PAUL IRISH: That's
a good answer.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm a big fan of
disruptive stuff, just because
I'm a big believer in what
the browser can do.
And so seeing this stuff
landing in the browser,
without plug-ins, it's
opened so many doors.
So, for me, it's WebRTC
for sure.
PAUL KINLAN: So just on that
point, we've been able to do
things which we've never
been able to do.
And I'm sorry for jumping in.
PAUL LEWIS: That's
good though.
I know where you're going.
PAUL KINLAN: Where am I going?
PAUL LEWIS: I think you'll
go with packaged app.
PAUL KINLAN: I am going
with packaged apps.
We hadn't even planned this.
It's so good.
We just connected.
The latest version of Chrome
Packaged Applications, for
instance, allows access to
network sockets, UDP, TCP.
You have Bluetooth, USB, all
these type of things, which
we've never had in the
browser before.
So yeah, that's another
one I'm very
excited about as well.
And I won't interrupt again.
ADDY OSMANI: Is that
a promise?
I believe you.
I'm most interested in anything
that helps developers
build applications more easily
and that factors into Yeoman.
I'm also really interested
in Web Components.
I see that being the future of
how people, perhaps, create
widgets and applications.
And perhaps there'll be less
of an emphasis on the
frameworks they use and more
about what the browser can
give you right out of the box.
So I think it's going to be
really exciting to see what
happens there.
Paul?
PAUL LEWIS: He's busy going left
while we're going right.
ADDY OSMANI: Just
say, everything.
PAUL IRISH: I know, right?
What are you going to go with?
SAM DUTTON: I'm not
going to tell you.
PAUL KINLAN: Well,
I'll tell you.
He was going to say,
Web Intents.
SAM DUTTON: I was going
to way Web Intents.
PAUL IRISH: I really like
all the things there.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, me too.
PAUL IRISH: One of the things
about WebRTC though is that--
a small thing, just
a small one--
it's still behind.
You have to go to [INAUDIBLE].
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: It's still
in Canary?
SAM DUTTON: Beta.
It's in stable, but it's
behind the flags.
PAUL IRISH: It's in stable?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
But it's behind flags.
PAUL IRISH: But in Canary
is it behind flags?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
In Canary--
oh god, I'm going to
get this wrong.
PAUL KINLAN: I thought beta was
still behind the flags.
ADDY OSMANI: I thought
beta was [INAUDIBLE].
SAM DUTTON: It's complicated.
Sorry.
Just--
a little explanation.
There were originally two flags
you needed to enable to
use WebRTC.
One was MediaStream.
One was PeerConnection.
What's happened is that it's
basically working that, as the
versions of Chrome come through,
you don't need to
enable MediaStream.
But PeerConnection, for the
actual peer-to-peer
communication stuff, still
needs to be enabled.
So what that means is that get
user media is available.
We will be coming with flagless
implementation, but,
for a while, PeerConnection
is behind a flag.
PAUL IRISH: And just
to clarify--
SAM DUTTON: Don't ask me to
remember which specific
versions it's in.
PAUL IRISH: Oh, it's fine.
Just to clarify, get user media
is the evolution of the
device tag from forever ago.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, kind of.
PAUL IRISH: So it's usually
just part of WebRTC.
But you don't need to be doing
in realtime communication with
anyone else.
You can just be using get user
media as a way to get access
to the camera, microphone--
SAM DUTTON: All that, yeah.
PAUL IRISH: But WebRTC with
PeerConnection is hugely powerful.
And even though it is available
pretty widely now,
behind a flag, I don't think
we've really seen a great
killer app with it.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, come on.
PAUL IRISH: The fact that I
connect to a peer, not send
all my bandwidth through a
server, so you can create,
essentially, a video chat app
that can scale beautifully.
Because all the connection
is peer-to-peer.
With things like noise
cancellation, duplex sound--
SAM DUTTON: Echo cancellation
and so on--
PAUL KINLAN: [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: And variable
bit rate, based on
your connection speed.
Them amount of technology that's
in there, things that
you don't have to worry about
is pretty incredible.
PAUL KINLAN: So one thing that
we would love to see is,
obviously, because there's the
PeerConnection API, and
[INAUDIBLE] and all
that type of stuff
you can build a server.
Like a client and the
peer-to-peer thing, which is
actually not a web browser,
it's just a web servelet.
Render a display buffer
to it, send it out.
I think it would be brilliant.
SAM DUTTON: That
is interesting.
PAUL KINLAN: You could just do
a whole lot of stuff with
that, and it would be cool.
SAM DUTTON: One of
the things--
PAUL KINLAN: We need to
experiment with it, right?
People need to do that.
Let's test it.
SAM DUTTON: One of the things,
just to reiterate a bit,
WebRTC, this is all about,
potentially, direct
peer-to-peer connection.
But there's a whole stack of
stuff built into WebRTC to
cope with NATraversal and
communication of streaming
data from behind the
firewalls and to
make that really seamless.
That's one of the
great strengths.
The other thing we'll be seeing
later in the year, we
hope or certainly is planned,
is DataChannel API.
At the moment, we've seen
WebRTC apps that
use the video stuff.
And what's planned is this API
called DataChannel, which does
the same thing, but for any
kind of arbitrary data, so
incredibly powerful.
PAUL KINLAN: Over peer-to-peer
WebSockets?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, peer-to-peer
data.
PAUL KINLAN: Right--
SAM DUTTON: Oh, come on.
PAUL KINLAN: You know when I
said I wouldn't interrupt?
We've actually had a remote
gate crasher.
Seth Wright wants us to say
Dart is his most exciting
platform feature.
ADDY OSMANI: That
surprises me.
SAM DUTTON: If you haven't
used Dart, give it a go.
Try it out.
I got to give one more plug
since it's my turn.
I've got to mention the track
element, which is really
interesting.
I think if you haven't had a
look at this, it's a really
simple way to get synchronized
timed metadata in with media ,
such as video and audio, so
simple use cases, stuff like
captions, subtitles.
But what makes it, for me,
really interesting, aside from
the accessibility stuff, is
the ability to use timed
metadata of any kind.
So you can have metadata that
relates to times within media
and do anything with that.
PAUL KINLAN: Do you want to tell
them about your example
that you did?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Shameless plug--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, go on.
It's good.
SAM DUTTON: Have a look
on HTML5 Rocks.
There's an article about
the track elements.
We did one in particular based
on some work some guys did
here at Google.
If you go to
samdutton.com/maptrack, you'll
see a demo there, which, like a
guy ride around on a cycle,
around the Mt View
Google campus.
And you can see that
synchronized with a pointer on
a map, and also like StreetView
of where he's going.
And that's all done using
the track element.
PAUL KINLAN: You'll see all
that, the geolocation, there's
the timed elements--
SAM DUTTON: It's
fairly simple.
It just had a geo file--
I used an XML file--
to create, in JavaScript,
the track data.
And yeah, that's it.
You'll need to have
Canary for that.
There's, again, a whole stack
stuff we're going to see.
Bring it on.
Good implementations.
ADDY OSMANI: I guess, since
we're talking about video and
WebRTC, this is an interesting
question for
Sam from Adam Bradley.
Do you see solutions like
PhoneGap still being useful if
we're able to capture audio and
video now from new HTML5
input fields and features?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
In the short term, certainly.
I mean, I don't see
these things as
excluding each other.
But I can see that the
functionality we get with
MediaStream, if you're using get
user media, that's the API
behind that MediaStream.
There's a lot of potential to
that stuff which is built
right into the browser.
And we'll see wider
implementations across
platforms--
PAUL KINLAN: I think it
depends right now.
It's like, if you're building
something that's specific for
Android and want specific
Android integrations, then
we're not quite there
just yet.
But look at the pace of change
we've had recently, just to
get where we're going.
It's pretty cool.
PAUL IRISH: The published
goal of PhoneGap is
to make itself obsolete.
So they want that.
So hopefully that happens.
SAM DUTTON: Right, where are
we with the questions?
PAUL KINLAN: We're on
[INAUDIBLE] updates.
PAUL IRISH: We got a
lot of questions.
So the next one is GreyGhost
Visuals asks why Chrome does
not support the rem unit inside
media queries and links
to a little demo where
that doesn't work.
PAUL KINLAN: So I'm naive.
I don't know what
the rem unit is.
Is it relative em's?
PAUL IRISH: Relative em's.
PAUL KINLAN: Is that
what it is?
PAUL IRISH: Jonathan Snook
has a really good
article about it.
It was a more recent one.
I'm not sure why.
PAUL KINLAN: Why would you
need it in a media query?
Is that in the actual filter--
PAUL IRISH: You're defining
a width that you want to
manipulate, that things are
going to change in.
So I think, actually,
for the media query
condition, not the payload.
PAUL KINLAN: But then, my only
question is, you normally put
media query stuff at the top of
the page, where you don't
even need a relative em.
You just need a normal em unit,
because that's where
it's based from, is it not?
PAUL IRISH: What I would suggest
on this is filing a
ticket and link it
to your demo.
So this is actually the first
time that I've heard that this
is an issue.
So it may not be on the mind of
anyone that could work on
it and fix it.
So file a ticket and just ping
me afterwards, and I'll try
and find an engineer who
can take a look.
We got three more minutes.
PAUL KINLAN: Can I answer one?
I promised I'd answer some
Web Intents questions.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, you did.
PAUL KINLAN: Cheers, dudes.
So it says, I'm currently
implementing a proof of
concept with Web Intents.
And I'm wondering is it
correct that I have to
implement a Chrome extension
to support an
intent at the moment?
Yeah, it's pretty correct
at the moment.
We don't have the full
tag support in any of
the browsers anyway.
We have a JavaScript shim
which emulates.
But that's incompatible with
pure Chrome implementation.
So right now, you have to either
have a Chrome extension
or a packaged app, where you
will define the actions and
the data type that you want to
work on and what URLs they
will launch inside the
manifest itself.
So, yes, right now, our ultimate
goal is to have the
manifest as an option, but have
something on the open
web, which will let you register
functionality with
the browser of your
application.
So we're not way off.
I mean, if you want to build
stuff, here today, Chrome,
Chrome extensions, Chrome apps,
they're pretty good.
They can be packaged apps or
hosted apps as well, so it
doesn't have to be packaged,
which most people think it is.
PAUL LEWIS: And is it worth
mentioning what Web Intents is
for the uninitiated?
PAUL KINLAN: There is no
one who is uninitiated.
I keep talking about
it all the time.
PAUL LEWIS: Really?
Hadn't noticed.
PAUL KINLAN: So Web Intents,
they're basically a way for
you to connect applications,
essentially.
It's an easy way to connect
web applications.
The idea, basically, is that
you'll have two applications,
which don't need to know about
each other to be able to talk.
So you might share a link from
a web page, and you, as the
user, get to choose your
preferred service for link
sharing, not the ones
that are deeply
integrated into the website.
It's like a discovery mechanism
for applications.
That's the highest
way of saying it.
And the pitch I normally do
is if you're familiar with
Android Intents, it's Android
Intents but for the web.
So that's the easiest way.
And then another Web Intents
question, someone's given me a
compliment that says--
ADDY OSMANI: That's
not a question.
PAUL KINLAN: It says, where
can I get the awesome--
I didn't get a compliment?
Fred, from London, where can I
get an awesome laptop skin?
I thought he said,
I was awesome.
Fred, from London, I can
probably send you one.
We'll meet up or something.
PAUL IRISH: [INAUDIBLE]?
PAUL KINLAN: He's in London,
so it's probably cool.
We'll sort something out.
I think we got some
gel skins here.
If not, our producer will
send us something.
PAUL IRISH: We've got a few.
And then we can actually post
the artwork file and you can
go order a custom one
from gelaskins.com.
Let's do that.
PAUL KINLAN: There is, actually,
one question right
at the bottom.
It's nothing to do with
what I've been
talking about at all.
When will voice input, within
the Chrome extension pop-up,
be working again?
There's actually a Chrome
extension API, which allows
you to not even require
a pop-up.
I believe it's experimental
still, so you can play with
that as well.
If it's not working, you might
want to look at that one.
PAUL IRISH: One last question.
ADDY OSMANI: So Pete from the UK
writes, can you give us any
specifics of the Yeoman plug-in
pattern and what the
library will provide?
How far down the add-task for
everything style are you
going, or at what point will the
developer be expected to
manage files and line endings
on their own?
So Yeoman is going to try as
much as possible to stay an
opinionated project.
We're going to provide tasks
for things that we think
people will use.
So we've got tasks to help with
things like required JS
and CoffeScript and Compass.
You don't, of course, have
to use those things.
But they're there in case
you do want to use them.
In terms of the plug-in pattern
that we use, it's
actually really, really
flexible.
You can include, in your
boilerplate or scaffold or
template or whatever you want to
call it, as many different
policies you want.
So if you're a framework, for
example, you can define the
models, the views, the
controllers, all the different
bits and pieces that
are required to
scaffold something out.
And it can be completely
up to your style.
It can be customized as
much as you want.
And we're going to be providing
a really solid set
of docs, right now, so at least
that you can go create
your own templates as
much as you want.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
And the last part of that, you
were asking about should
developers manage files
and line endings?
As far as line endings
are concerned--
in the projects we generate?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: Editor Config.
Go to editorconfig.org.
It's kind of an emerging
standard that the jQuery
Project Modernizr, Agent
[INAUDIBLE], a lot of projects
are getting.
It just sets up a very few
number of rules as far as
white space preferences, like
carriage return, line feed,
style things, and has plug-ins
for editors so that the
editors keep all these files
consistent across these
environments.
And this is something that
we think is awesome.
And so we have it as
part of Yeoman.
I guess that's it for
this Office Hours.
Awesome time with three
Pauls in London.
ADDY OSMANI: And
the rest of us.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Who all--
PAUL LEWIS: The non-Pauls.
ADDY OSMANI: The non-Pauls.
PAUL LEWIS: Thank you very
much for joining us.
ADDY OSMANI: Thank you.
PAUL KINLAN: So are we going
to try and make this a
relatively regular thing as
well, probably on Thursdays,
probably about the same time?
I'm always going to talk
about Web Intents.
PAUL IRISH: So next time you
see a message go out on
Twitter or G+, click through
the link, ask some more
questions, vote up and down.
And we'd love to answer
everything we can for you.
PAUL KINLAN: And enjoy
the Olympics.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah,
We'll see you guys next time.
SAM DUTTON: Thank you.
PAUL KINLAN: Bye.
SAM DUTTON: See you.